so um
okay let me just start
so uh this is the program page of
metagenomics data analysis and as you
can see that the program is going to
commence from next week Thursday that is
22nd of September
now if I'll scroll down you can see a
program overview which will tell you why
this particular program is designed what
all uh
things and aspects we'll be covering in
this program about like for example
operational taxonomic units then
functional bacterial Community data to
pipelines kind pipelines Etc
and further if it if you'll scroll down
you can see an interactive session where
there are few dates highlighted so which
means that the uh on these particular
dates the session will be conducted
either asynchronous or live sessions
would be there so that would be uh like
we will uh mailing you out about each
session
on the right hand side you can see the
curriculum of the program
the topics per each session that is for
example the first session that is on
22nd it is on introduction to
metagenomics where we'll be covering the
16s metagenomic sequencing
then introduction to NGS for metagenomic
sequencing overview of the tools and
resources for this program and then
there are some Associated online
resources per session when you scroll
down you can see the second session
title the topics we will be covering and
then again the associated online
resources and same goes on
for the third session after the third
session there will be an in-depth
Hands-On project example which will be
on American gut and human microbiome
variability and the topics which we'll
be covering is related to gut brain
access microbiome and behavior use of
small subunit 16s RNA for identification
of microorganism metagenomics data to
Chao versus hft
Etc and then there are few Associated
online resources
so here you can see the comprehensive
curriculum which we have developed for
this metagenomic data analysis program
if you scroll down further you can see
three different tenures for which you
can enroll for
the three different tenures are one is
of 45 days 60 days and then 90 days the
common resources which are there which
is applicable for all three tenures are
online tutorials project examples coding
sessions session recordings online meant
to support via our Skype groups or
telegram groups Online technical support
uh
then certificate after completion of the
program and example Cloud pipelines on
t-bar and per server so these are some
of the common resources which you will
get away now what's the difference
between the three resource per tenures
so in 45 days you will be going through
with an extensive training
right in 60 days you have an opportunity
with the extensive training you can work
on your research proposal and present it
to our Mentor for evaluation and
feedback
and other than that you have an
opportunity of one-on-one mental
sessions in 90 days you have an
opportunity to work on an independent
research project with extensive training
and again one-on-one Mentor sessions are
there so the outcome for 60 days uh
program would be post a presentation in
omics research Symposium or any other
International Conference and outcome for
the 90-day tenure is the research
publication and a good peer-reviewed
Journal so this was a brief about the
program resources the fee structure okay
so now you can see here the fee here you
can see like on the right top uh right
top corner there is a flag and a drop
down menu
if you'll click on that you can see
there are different currencies according
to different country or location so
according to your location you can
choose your currency for now right now I
I'll be opting for USD in dollars so the
fee for 45 days is dollar 150 for 60
days it's dollar 300 and for 90 days
it's dollar 450 and obviously we are
giving scholarships to those who are
like uh those are those are in financial
aid or something so we will be giving
scholarships so you can mail us at
marketing at the rate omicslogic.com
so I'll be just writing the mail ID here
in the chat box and you can mail us
for further queries or scholarships so
this was a brief about the curriculum
the structure
program structure the fee structure and
the resources
now I could see that there is a quite
this there is a quiet discussion going
in going on in the chat box regarding
team and hackathon and so I'll quickly
uh navigate you or walk you through the
landing page of the hackathon so we are
really very excited to launch our
hackathon that is on theme microbiome in
Health and Wellness
and so this hackathon like it will bring
together innovative ideas from
biotechnology and the intersection of
genomics business and computer science
so here the students the researchers
across the globe will like they'll have
an opportunity to broaden their Horizons
by meeting different people meeting uh
experts uh from commercial commercial
experts or academic experts or research
experts and uh having their valuable
feedback and uh brainstorming with them
Etc so we'll be uh in like we'll be in
some duration we'll be rolling out mails
and we'll be publishing on our social
media platforms on LinkedIn uh then
Instagram or Facebook or Twitter about
this hackathon so the theme of the
hackathon revolves around
it looks like the screen is not shared
for the hackathon page
okay okay I'm uh okay so I'll just stop
sharing my screen and I'll share it
again
in just a moment
okay so uh
now is it visible
okay perfect
so as I was saying that uh we are quite
excited to launch a hackathon that is
that the title of the uh hackathon is on
microbiome in health health and wellness
soon we'll be rolling out some mails and
Publishing on our social media handles
about the hackathon how you can register
further for the hackathon
so uh the
hackathon like the hackathon will get
start from uh like comments from
November one and it will end on November
28th so the three weeks like from
November 1 till November 22 there will
be some workshops going on for weekly
basis and uh the categories for those
Workshop will be developing cutting-edge
Technologies it will include omics and
microbiome merogenomic sequencing then
uh talks related to bioinformatics
recommendation Etc week two Workshop
will be related to human microbiome
Titan supplement where we including a
talks related to gut microbiome health
and diet skin microbiome Beauty comfort
and aging and also vaginal microbiome
pregnancy and fembroke and the third
week will be devoted to computer science
and machine learning where we'll be
learning about the infrastructure for
computational analysis tool methods and
algorithm data visualization and
experience user experience
so um
talking about the team costing
this particular hackathon like students
can participate in group group of three
minimum three or maximum five right and
you can make group either like your
colleagues or your peers from same
University or maybe from same industry
or you can even connect via LinkedIn as
I could see one of the participant was
asking for like who is like interested
in teaming up with her
so uh that's a like that's a great idea
by this you can uh broaden Your Horizon
and uh like
spread more Roots into different
networks and networking people Etc
so now uh the costing for individual
student is dollar hundred
if you will come in a group then it's
dollar 300 per group a group three to
five students and uh we have some
special discounts for our partner
University so it is dollar 100 per group
which include three students in the
group so this was a brief about the
hackathon and uh the registration
everything we'll be disclosing soon
uh so you will be getting mails you will
be seeing social post on our uh social
media handles so through if further you
have any query related to hackathon or
related to the registration part of the
metagenomics data analysis program
please feel free to put your queries in
the chat box and I'll be here to answer
thank you
so special there's one query that is can
all these links and email be mailed to
our registered emails uh yes uh
definitely so uh once uh like uh this
will be mailing you out the session
recordings as well as all these links
like the program page link which I just
showed you related to metagenom data
analysis and the hackathon page link as
well to your registered email address
uh then we have another query that is uh
please share the recorded version of the
webinar or training I missed part of it
yeah sure so uh we'll be rolling out uh
the recorded version of this webinar uh
tomorrow
and uh please do check your Promotional
and Spam folders because sometimes uh
males Land open